lisa gallagher as we told you a moment
ago is one of the many trump supporters
who woke up to an fbi raid earlier this
month and we are grateful that she's
willing to join us to tell us about it
lisa thank you so much for coming on so
i just want to be clear that you have
not committed a crime of any kind i
don't think you've ever been accused of
a crime you weren't even at the capitol
on january 6 i don't think you're even
in washington tell us how you felt when
joe biden's fbi showed up with guns at
your home the morning after his speech
i was terrified and i'll be honest with
you when my daughter woke me up telling
me there were three
armed fbi officers at my door i thought
she was joking
and i immediately tried to throw clothes
on i called my husband i was crying my
knees were shaking and even though i
knew i'd done nothing wrong after seeing
joe biden's speech the night before i
thought oh my god this is political
and i was frightened i truly thought
they can take me out of here in
handcuffs and i thought i'm in my
bedroom i thought am i not coming home
so i went outside
and i said gentlemen you're scaring me
and they proceeded to tell me that they
were given an anonymous tip that i was
at the capitol on january 6th
even though of course as we said they
knew you weren't because they had facial
recognition software and there's no
evidence and it's almost almost two
years ago do you know who this anonymous
tip this snitch who turned you into
federal law enforcement for supporting
trump on facebook might
be no i know nothing and i invited them
into my home so i can look at my phone
and my calendar
and i have subsequently called the fbi
office in newark to
just document or know for sure that it
really was fbi agents at my home and it
was
and they said it was an anonymous tip
but they won't tell me anything else
yeah because there are not enough law
enforcement concerns right now with 107
000 americans dying of fentanyl last
year lisa gallery i know it takes
bravery to come on and explain what
happened to you i think only when people
do that will it end and so i'm doubly
grateful that you did this for us
tonight thank you so much
thank you tucker
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight